your brain doesn't know the difference
between an event that you have closed
your eyes and imagined and an event that
you've actually done and so here's
what's really cool what I just told you
is manifesting manifesting done
correctly is when you use your
procedural memory as a tool to train
your brain your nervous system your
spirit to help you feel motivated and to
help you do the work that actually
changes your life how cool is that I
want to be very clear about something
you know manifesting gets a bad rap
because of the Law of Attraction but
manifesting is not woo-woo at all it's
not a Cheesy topic manifesting is not
just think about something that you want
and suddenly it'll magically appear
manifesting is when you use your
procedural memory and you visualize the
step-by-step actions that you need to
take in order to make your big goal to
become a reality you see manifesting
isn't the end everybody manifesting is
the bridge it's the series of actions
that you're gonna take in order to have
this new habit need motivation you
better watch a top ten We Believe Nation
hey it's Evan Carmichael and I make
these videos because you are probably
the most ambitious person in your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that Push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best Mel Robbins
and my take on her top 10 rules for
success
rule number two be a good influence when
I hear the word leadership I think about
influence so let's first talk about what
is the word influence actually mean okay
so influence is the power that you have
to affect the actions behaviors and
opinions of other people in short it
means you have the influence to move
somebody from point A to point B now
there are two kinds of influence that
all leaders have
internal influence
and that's the power that you have over
yourself
and in my opinion this type of influence
is the single most important type of
influenced practice and cultivate that
will impact your ability to impact
others internal influence is your
ability to move yourself from point A to
point B
because one of the things about being a
great leader is knowing how to be
flexible knowing how to change knowing
how to Pivot knowing how to grow and
that means you've got to have influence
over yourself the other type of
influence is external influence and that
is your ability to move other people
from point A to point B you know we all
have had these experiences right where
we've uh been around other leaders we've
been around people that have had that
implied influence right because of their
position because of their title but I
guarantee you you've had the experience
where you've had to work for or been
around another leader
but they have not been that influential
on you
they were either a jerk or a
micromanager or they showed up in a way
that made you feel awful you have had
that experience and one of the reasons
why I want to hammer home this point
that it doesn't matter who you are where
you are what you do leadership the best
kind of leadership and the most powerful
kind of influence is the type that's
earned it has nothing to do with your
position it has nothing to do with your
title it has everything to do with how
you show up and the way in which you
treat other people I want you to
understand that the most important
aspect of raising your influence and of
becoming a better and a more influential
leader is
deciding that you want to be
and claiming that that leadership role
in your life when you look at leadership
and Brendan's right it's super important
that you're a student your whole life
that leadership is something that you
should study when you start to look into
leadership you're going to see that
there's all kinds of books there's all
kinds of philosophies there are servant
based leaders there are transformational
leaders there are situational leaders
there are people who are authoritarian
leaders there's a bazillion different
leadership styles well what I want you
to think about is what kind of leader do
you want to be and there are two
questions that I think are important for
you to ask yourself and the reason why
it's important for you to ask yourself
these two questions is because they will
give you a road map that maps to your
values and maps to your goals and maps
to who you are in terms of cultivating a
leadership style rule number three learn
the skill of confidence my definition of
confidence is not belief in self
what you're going to learn about Mel
Robbins is that I love evidence-based
advice
because I'm kind of skeptical
now I was trained as a lawyer life has
kicked me up it kicked me around a
little bit I kind of crossed my eyes at
people that are very kind of
motivational
and you know I'm like well it's easy to
do the inspirational stuff but what's
the depth right what's the depth
and so when I think about confidence and
my definition of confidence I looked at
the research on confidence okay and
there's really good news here the first
thing you've already learned it's a
skill
the second thing that you are going to
learn that's really good is it's it's
very simple to build the skill of
confidence and you can do it through
repetitive actions every day very simple
little things that will slowly build up
the reservoir of confidence and here's
the definition I want to give you of
confidence
confidence is the willingness to try
that's it
I'm going to say it again
confidence is the willingness to try
that's it
that's all that it is and the reason why
I like this definition is because this
definition that I have created for
confidence which is the willingness to
try
is based in the research around
confidence
so if you want to learn more about this
Google
confidence
competency Loop okay I'm going to show
it to you I'm hoping that that this is
not broadcasting backwards okay this is
my fancy little graphic okay this is
what we call a confidence competency
loop I did not invent this this is
something that people who research
confidence for a living have created
and I've highlighted this because this
is where confidence begins it begins
with the willingness to try because I'm
going to show you what ends up happening
if you're the kind of person
who trains yourself notice the words I'm
using trains we're not going to sit
around and wait for motivation we're not
going to wait for courage we're going to
manufacture those things and this is
where the five second rule is so
transformative
now for those of you that don't know it
I'm not going to spend a lot of time
explaining it I'm going to give it give
you the shortcut it's just a simple
brain hack backed by tremendous evidence
that I created at the worst moment of my
life that turns out to have
extraordinary science behind it
all you do is in a moment where you feel
doubt insecurity fear anxiety
procrastination perfectionism PTSD OCD
anything that you might possibly have
that would rise up to block you you
simply count backwards five four three
two one okay and you gotta count
backwards five four three two one and
what that will do is it will shift gears
in your mind instead of being stuck here
in the part of the brain that keeps you
stuck worrying and thinking and having a
bias towards overthinking and being a
perfectionist you're going to go one
fourth or five four three two one and
you're going to try
now this is what's going to happen
the first time you try you will fail
that's really good news you want to know
why you learn by failing
you learn by failing do you realize
that's how you've always learned
that when you were a kid you don't
remember this but when you were learning
to walk
you fell an average of 17 times an hour
you actually learned to walk by Falling
and so you learn everything when you
fail because when you fail as much as
you may think you're gonna die if you
stand on a stage I see a lot of you who
want to be coaches or speakers or
whatever you're going to have to learn
how to give a speech where you stutter
and where your your mouth gets really
dry and pasty and where you get a neck
rash and where you forget what you're
supposed to say you got to do all that
stuff why because when you fail you
don't die you actually gain knowledge
and experience
and that's the gift of failure because
you then take that knowledge and that
experience and you go right back to the
next time and then you try again but
this time when you 54321 try
you're going to take your knowledge and
experience with you and you're going to
fail a little bit less
and what you're going to learn there
you're going to take right back to the
next time that you try and every time
that you fail you're gaining knowledge
and experience and you take that to the
next time that you try and you're gonna
go like this and you're gonna go like
this and you're going to keep going and
going and going and going and going and
every time
you five four three two one
you push yourself to try
you gain a little bit of Competency for
the next time you're going to do it and
every time you gain a little bit of
Competency your Mastery goes up
and that's when you start to feel more
self-assured
and that muscle everybody of trying
that is where you build the skill of
confidence which is the willingness to
not be so damn serious and hung up on
being perfect and being worried about
looking stupid and instead you're
willing to lean in and try something
rule number four start changing what is
it that you want to create
or change in your life okay I want you
to write something down it could be
something tiny that there's like a
specific thing that you want to change a
specific habit or it could be something
really big and it's important that we
start there because I want you to have
the thing that you want in mind
as I'm talking okay what is it that you
want to create in 2022 wealth stability
you want to stop
procrastinating right you want to create
Independence you want to feel like
you're aligned you want to uh get your
education you want to change your
exercise and eating habits you don't
want to be a passenger in somebody
else's life anymore you want to be The
Driver of your own life that's fantastic
and as I talk and as I teach I want you
to continue to think about this goal
that you have to think about this change
that you want to make okay and what
we're going to talk a lot about today
is we're going to talk about this
principle
that I believe
and the principle is this
profound personal and professional
change starts with you
that's right profound personal and
professional change starts with you
and change starts with you because the
most effective change starts from the
inside out okay and so as you think
about a behavior change or a thinking
pattern change that you want to make or
some sort of goal or dream I want you to
take everything that I'm about to teach
you
and have that example in mind okay so
that everything that I'm talking about
isn't just stuff I'm doing in my life
isn't just stuff that you read about uh
when you look at the research in terms
of habits and manifesting but you
actually walk away with takeaway that is
specific to what you want to achieve
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business business
I'll see you there rule number five set
new habits the reason why habits are so
important everybody
is because based on uh research this is
from a study that was published uh a
couple years ago that 40 percent of your
behavior are what we call Habits
habits
that's just another word for patterns
okay and so I'm going to give you some
examples
of habits that you might not even think
about are a habit okay
and a pattern or a habit is simply
a behavior pattern we call them a loop
and I'm going to explain why
it's a behavior pattern
that is stored in the subconscious part
of the brain you'll also often hear
people talk about the basal ganglia and
the reason why you have habits is
because your brain loves shortcuts see
everything that your brain is doing and
your nervous system is doing we've
talked a lot about this in other
trainings but everything that your brain
and your nervous system is doing it
requires fuel just like your car
requires fuel for you to be able to go
from where you are right now to the
grocery store that's how it runs your
brain requires fuel
and your brain has figured out ways to
maximize
the fuel and to be more efficient and
the way that your brain is more
efficient is it learns habits and
patterns
and when you have a habit or a pattern
that you have memorized because you've
repeated it so many times it takes less
fuel for your brain to reflexively do
that pattern than doing something new
and I'll give you an example
um this is something you can test out
later today or tomorrow
I want you to think about like a place
that you often bike or drive to maybe
it's a grocery store maybe it's work
maybe it's school maybe it's friends
house
tomorrow I want you to consciously drive
an entirely new and different and longer
way and you will notice something you
will notice that your brain fights you
you will notice that your brain is
annoyed and you will notice that it
takes more effort for you to think about
where you're headed
because the way that you commute to work
or school or the grocery store you have
repeated that so many times it is now a
pattern or a habit Loop stored in your
brain that's why often you get to places
you always drive and you're like oh my
God who drove the car because you don't
remember driving the car because your
brain was in the background making
decisions that have already been
automated so the reason why that happens
just in summary is because if you had to
use your prefrontal cortex and focus on
every aspect and every decision from how
you pick up the toothbrush to how you
hold a pencil to all that stuff you
literally would need to take a you'd
need to take a nap by one o'clock in the
afternoon you wouldn't be able to
process that much new information
and so it's a way for your brain to take
a break it learns patterns automates
behaviors so let me give you some
examples of some habits you might not
think about
picture yourself
sitting at the wheel of a car
and you put the car in Reverse which
shoulder do you look over as you're
backing up
it's always the same one isn't it and
depending upon where you live in the
world it's one side of the other
it's always the same you don't even
think about it do you
that right there is a habit
that is a reflexive action and pattern
that you do without even thinking
now think about your evening routine do
you lock the door every night
at home do you have a pattern or habit
of things that you just go through in
your house reflect you don't even think
about it right
you're not like oh it's time to lock the
door about where is the door I can't
remember how to do I better Fortune no
you just get up you walk to click the
lock and it's just a pattern that you do
that is triggered by the end of the
night
here's the second thing I want you to
know about patterns
patterns repeat
patterns repeat
if you don't
interrupt a pattern
and replace it with something else the
pattern will repeat forever
so learning new behaviors and learning
new habits
is a lot more
about spotting the things that you don't
want to do anymore
and interrupting them
and then replacing those old patterns
with new patterns
and I believe that when you start to
feel broken or stuck in your life
you're not broken you have a pattern
from your past that makes you feel
broken based on where you want to go now
and I also believe that when you feel
stuck in life you're not actually stuck
you're just stuck repeating these old
patterns and until you catch them
and you interrupt them which is where
the five second rule comes in there's
nothing more powerful to help you
interrupt an old pattern than counting
backwards five four three two one to
interrupt the loop but then you have to
replace it with something else
because if you don't replace the pattern
what's rule number one about patterns
patterns repeat
so you can't just break a habit
technically you don't break a habit
technically you replace it with
something else rule number six plan your
journey one of the things that has
happened uh certainly in the pandemic
but it always happens when there's any
kind of Reckoning in your life is that
when you have something suddenly happen
and your life is fundamentally changed
whether it's a death or somebody says I
don't love you anymore or you're fired
or you find yourself uh with a scary
Health diagnosis there is a line in the
sand there is a life before
that happened and then a life after that
moment happened and that line in the
sand that Reckoning that happens and it
happens for all of us whether it's
happening for you right now or it has
happened in the past I'm telling you
there is a gift inside of this even the
darkest moments because every single
Sudden Change in your life that makes
you feel like you've lost control and
you no longer know where you're going
it's like hitting the giant pause button
and if you lean into the moment
there is a chance for tremendous wisdom
and growth there are things that you can
do right now in order to take control of
where you're going of what you're
thinking about and you can start to take
this moment of change and you can use it
to be able to take and make an
intentional pivot in the direction that
is meant for you next and one of the
things I want to say about this moment
is look if you're losing loved ones you
are terrified this has made you lose
your job you feel like you're in that
moment where everything you know you're
falling off a cliff you're trying to
pack a parachute you're grieving and so
you got to give yourself space to grieve
the losses that you're feeling
and when you get a little bit of
distance from The Grieving and the ways
of grief and fear that you're feeling
start to space out they don't ever leave
you but over time those waves of holy
cow and I don't want this and I can't
handle this and why is this happening to
me
time will start to lessen those waves
you will gather your feet underneath you
again and you will absolutely
be stronger and be a better version of
yourself based on this incredible
challenge that you're facing and I can
say that even though you may be facing
in a tough time because if you think
about your life you faced extraordinary
challenges and there hasn't been a
single one that hasn't made you a better
and stronger version of yourself and
this moment will be no different
so I want you to understand that when
you get out of the cycle of grief this
is an enormous Reckoning an enormous
opportunity for you to hit the pause
button and for you to start to ask
yourself the question what do I want my
life to look like
because I think too many of us are
sitting here going I can't wait for my
life to get back to normal I can't wait
for this to end I can't wait to things
to go back to normal and in any moment
of Reckoning what happens is there's
actually parts of your old life
that you don't want to go back to
and there is a tremendous amount that
you're learning in this moment that you
need to pause and take in and say okay
based on what I've just learned based on
my old life when I look ahead to my new
life what is it that I want my new life
to look like this next chapter I can
turn to a blank page I can take all this
wisdom all this resilience all this
strength and I can write something new
that's what I want you to know you don't
need to know where the world or where
everything is headed you just need to
know where you're gonna head next rule
number seven set boundaries with people
I used to be the kind of person that had
zero boundaries I mean not a nothing
zilch nothing in fact there were periods
of my life where it was worse than zero
because I was so attached in romantic
relationships that I literally would
become like a human amoeba in my
romantic relationships I mean I was like
literally really if it's possible to
have negative boundaries meaning you
like somehow go in a totally different
direction that was me and so if somebody
as insecure and as uh emotionally
attached in relationships and as people
pleasing as me can figure out how to
identify communicate and uphold
boundaries in my life you can learn how
to do this too okay and so that's what
we're going to unpack in this video
so I think a big question because a lot
of people talk about boundaries they
know they need boundaries but they don't
have good boundaries why is that well
the reason why we don't have good
boundaries is because none of us were
trained how to set them I mean I want
you to think about your childhood for a
minute your childhood with your
caregivers your parents your
grandparents whoever it is naturally an
imbalance right like when you come into
this world you are born into a
particular family you're born into a
particular culture religion economic
situation a place in the world a race
like a religion and based on where you
were born and to whom you were born into
in terms of the family structure there
were all kinds of rules that you had to
follow and if you did not follow those
rules
there were consequences and so can you
imagine if you as like an eight-year-old
started to try to express boundaries
literally like mom cooks a uh you know a
pot pot roast dinner and you cross your
arms you're like you know Mom
uh this is a boundary cross for me I
have decided that I am no longer eating
meat uh your mom would probably go guess
what youngster
you not eating dinner is a boundary
Crossing for me you're not getting up
from this table until you finish what's
on your plate and so saying boundaries
when you're little doesn't really work
for the adults in your life and that's
why you never learn how to do it and by
the way your parents were probably never
taught how to have boundaries either and
so
I want to start at the very beginning
okay
where do you even begin
where do you even begin when it comes to
learning how to set healthy boundaries
okay so first things first where you're
going to begin is you're going to start
to think about boundaries in a
completely new way okay the number one
mistake that we all make I made it
you're making it right now is when you
think about boundaries you are thinking
about other people first okay you're
thinking about boundaries uh and
believing that your boundaries are rules
in a relationship that define respect
and that somehow your boundaries are
going to control or change someone
else's Behavior that is the exact
opposite of how you should be thinking
about boundaries okay I didn't realize
this this is why I was lousy at setting
boundaries because I thought that my
boundaries control what other people do
no no no no no no so how do I want you
to think about boundaries okay
boundaries are rules that you create
about your own behavior
and I'm gonna take this a little bit
further now
what I'm actually talking about is I'm
going to help you identify situations
people
um any kind of experience you might find
yourself in
where your boundary defines what you're
going to do in reaction to something
that's going on around you okay because
I think what I'm seeing a lot of online
or two things
it's this sort of quick Instagram advice
where it's like you've crossed a
boundary you're a toxic person you're no
longer in my life when the truth is the
behavior that we really need to be
policing is our own the opportunity for
growth and the way the boundaries can
support you is in looking at what you
need to change when it comes to certain
people certain situations or certain
choices and habits that you have okay
and we're gonna unpack this don't worry
but I really want to kind of land here
because if you start to turn the focus
back on yourself you're going to have a
much easier time with
applying the five rules around
boundaries that I'm about to teach you
okay so rule number one
always focus on yourself
what you will and what you won't allow
okay always focus on yourself what you
will and won't allow do not try to
control other people because you can't
okay think about boundaries as
guardrails that you set for yourself and
I'm going to give you a quick example we
all have that relative that loves to
hear them talk about politics right like
it's super annoying they're constantly
going on and on about politics okay and
you
want this relative of yours to stop
talking about politics around you okay
what if I told you that expressing a
boundary with a relative telling them to
stop talking about politics around you
will probably only increase the
likelihood that they're going to
and so the better way to think about
boundaries is not
what do I need to say to Uncle Joe so
that Uncle Joe does not talk about
politics around me
that's not how you do this you don't go
Uncle Joe you're crossing a line with me
you're crossing a boundary I need you to
stop talking about politics
let's just role play that for a minute
how do you think that's going to work
that ain't gonna work very well is it no
because then Uncle Joe's gonna flare up
and then you're gonna flare up and now
instead of having a boundary that you
held you've got a gigantic mess that's
been made instead you got to think about
that boundary with you okay
what are you going to do and there are
two examples of this you could decide
that if that relative starts sounding
off about politics
that is a boundary for you and you will
remove yourself from the room
that's an example of how you can set a
boundary
another example is you could say
something to Uncle Joe and you could say
hey Uncle Joe
I love you
and I'd love to have you over for dinner
but if you plan on talking about
politics when we're together
We're not gonna have dinner
you have defined what you will tolerate
and not you didn't say do not talk about
politics you said I love you if we're
gonna have dinner together I'd love to
have you over for dinner
but not if we're talking politics
you've given Uncle Joe the option to
talk politics or not you've just made it
clear where you stand which is we're not
having dinner together if you opt to do
that do you see how that's about your
behavior
you've made it clear what you're gonna
do but Uncle Joe now has a choice to
either respect the boundary or not rule
number eight build Integrity fulfillment
is when you're satisfied
because you are fully developing
your deepest desires
and your character
fulfillment's very different than
happiness everybody
happiness comes and goes happiness is
fleeting happiness is like the waves
in an ocean or the waves on Lake
Michigan the Great Lakes here in the
United States which is where I grew up
on Lake Michigan
the waves they come and they go right
that's happiness it comes and it goes it
rauls in and out of your life and
oftentimes it feels like it's out of
your control
fulfillment is the ocean or the Great
Lakes itself
fulfillment is something way deeper
and fulfillment is about integrity
and meaning
and the fact that when you have
integrity and meaning in your life you
are fulfilled
you are satisfied because you are
fulfilling and fully developing your
deepest desires
and your character
and this is important and I'm going to
really Hammer these words around meaning
and more importantly integrity
if I had to pick one word that was
important when it comes to you deepening
your level of fulfillment with your
whole life
the word is integrity
now this was brand new to me
you know I always thought about
fulfillment like oh find your joy find
your passion find your purpose like then
you'll be fulfilled
do things that you love you'll be
fulfilled it actually has more to do
with integrity
which is really cool and you know when I
explain why Integrity is so important
it's also going to illuminate all the
places in your life where you're not
fulfilled because I guarantee you
the places in your life where you're
missing fulfillment are also lacking
personal integrity
you're not operating
consistently with what you care about
you're not operating with Integrity in
terms of your values you're not spending
your time your energy and your resources
on what truly aligns with you from an
Integrity standpoint and so that's why
we're going to continue to hammer this
word integrity okay and that's great
because when you start to think about
cultivating personal integrity and how
that translates to more fulfillment in
your life it's going to make that
fulfillment something that you can
control it's going to make it deeply
personal it's going to make it something
that you can move the needle on it puts
the locus of control within your reach
let me talk about the two mistakes that
everybody makes okay when it comes to
fulfillment and this is why fulfillment
in some areas of your life
are Out Of Reach right now number one
the number one mistake that we make if
you're struggling with fulfillment in
any area of your life is that you're not
living according to your own values
you know I think we've all gone through
those periods of Our Lives where we are
drinking too much or we're spending too
much money or we're hanging out with the
wrong people or we're making unhealthy
choices and you know deep down inside
that this is not what you want to be
doing it's not what you should be doing
but because you are not living based on
your own values you don't respect
yourself
there's no way you're going to live a
fulfilled life if at the base level you
don't respect the choices that you're
making so can you identify an area of
your life right now either in the chat
or in the journal uh function in the app
an area of your life where you are not
living according to your own values I
see Health coming up for people I'm sure
if you think about how you're spending
your money or whether or not you're
saving money you're not aligned with
your values maybe you're doing work I
see productivity I see exercise so if
you're not living according to your own
values this is one reason why you're not
going to be fulfilled in your life
the second thing is that you spend your
time and your resources on things that
actually don't matter to you
you're spending your time and your
resources on things that don't matter to
you at the deepest level
these are the two big mistakes that we
all make and the good news here is that
these are mistakes that you can easily
identify that you can address and when
you do you take control back and you
will amp up the level of fulfillment
that you feel I'm going to say this
again
fulfillment is not the same thing as
happiness
fulfillment is meaning and integrity
and that's why habit number one and
building a foundation is about values
because you will only find fulfillment
true lasting deep fulfillment everybody
if you are following your values like a
compass
not your mood
you gotta follow your values and let
that be your compass that's how you
build the proper Foundation
and so what does that mean what does
that mean everybody well it means you
got to figure out what matters to you
okay and then you must develop the
simple discipline
to spend your time and energy on things
people experiences that align with what
matters to you
living with Integrity to what matters to
you is the secret of fulfillment
and I think you know I've alluded to
this earlier but you know I can think
about times in my life when either what
I was doing for work
or what I was doing with my free time
did not align with my values rule number
nine have fun in life I haven't lost
anybody
that I love
so I would not say what I'm about to say
if somebody that I loved had died in
this pandemic
but I have found the great pause
that the last two months have forced me
to take to be the greatest gift
that I have received in the last decade
my kids have been home
I have been off the road I have been
forced to slow down
I have been reminded of what actually
matters your health your family your
friends
what you're doing to take care of your
mind and your body and your spirit
and making sure that you do something
with the time that you have that you
really really enjoy and the other thing
that it's really made me stop and think
about is making sure that I'm having fun
that my whole life isn't just work
and it's made me really start to think
about the fact that I don't want to go
back to the life that I was living
before the pandemic hit
how many of you feel that way
that this has been a gigantic mental
perspective switch reset button that has
boom hit you really hard and Rule Number
10 the last one before some very special
bonus Clips is prioritize sleep the
things that you need to do
in order to increase Wellness
confidence
purpose a sense of control when it comes
to day-to-day habits in your home life
or at work
are really boring on their face
and so
I am coming out of the gates to say that
because the more successful I Have
Become
the happier I Have Become
the more boring my life looks on paper
I'm not kidding the things I'm about to
share with you are not sexy
they are not exciting
but they are the foundation
for everything that you want and that
you deserve in your life so we're going
to talk first okay when it comes to
Wellness
about something that you may not think a
lot about
because when you're building a business
when you're going for your dreams when
you are pursuing a big passionate life
you think about all the stuff that
you're doing right
one of the most important things when it
comes to Wellness strategies for home
and for work is sleep
period
the more successful that I've become the
you know the more boring my life looks
and the more sleep that I get
my husband and I are in bed by 9 30 on
most nights and the reason why is
because I know the science around sleep
now it's kind of boring to to tell it to
you so I'm going to just give you some
of the highlights
it is impossible for your brain for your
body and for your spirit to do what it's
been designed to do if you have not
given it the rest that it deserves
the research on this is just something
you can't argue with
it is so horrible for your brain when
you do not get a good night's sleep
the research shows that not only does it
impact your mood but when you do not
have enough sleep let's talk with uh you
know an all-nighter if you've ever
pulled an all-nighter I used to be the
queen of the all-nighters in college and
in law school
when you pull an all-nighter the
all-nighters impact on your brain is the
equivalent to head trauma it actually
shrinks your prefrontal cortex the part
of the brain that you need in order to
be able to focus in order to be able to
learn new behavior and so sleep is
essential if you want to be successful
you must prioritize your sleep if you
want a sense of wellness and in health
you must prioritize your sleep
I I read this study once that if you've
got three days in a row where you get
less than six hours of sleep at night
it is the equivalent
of being legally drunk when it comes to
your speed of processing your ability to
focus and so one of these foundational
principles when it comes to your success
and your Wellness both at home and at
work is you making sleep a serious
priority so what are some tactical
takeaways you know I'm going to steal
something from Brandon that he posted
that you may have seen on his uh his
Instagram page because it is an
excellent summary of what we call a wind
down routine morning routines right now
are all the rage how many of you have a
morning routine right you rely on your
morning routine how you set your day up
is how the day ends up but your morning
routine doesn't begin in the morning
everybody
it begins the night before
it begins with you going to bed at a
reasonable hour and it begins with you
completing your day and winding your day
down in a way that sets you up for
Success Brendan posted this post that I
just love that he called the three two
one formula three hours before bed you
stop eating two hours before bed you
stop working one hour before bed no more
screens and you want to know why
anything that's on a screen is somebody
else's dream
your dreams deserve a great night's
sleep
your dreams deserve your focus and
attention
and so I want you to be mindful about
how you wind down your day the three two
one principle from Brendan we're
stealing it here one hour beforehand
you're gonna turn off your screens the
next thing that I want you to do is
absolutely no phone in the bedroom
you're going to hear me talk about this
incessantly and the reason why is you're
addicted to it this does not belong in
your bedroom okay
and the reason why I don't want it in
the bedroom is because I want you to
have a good night's sleep and this this
is in Arms Reach you're gonna lay in bed
and look at it and that's going to
interrupt your ability to sleep in
addition the blue light for this uh on
the phone even when you're asleep it
interrupts your ability to drift into
the deeper REM sleep and you want to
know the the actual purpose of sleep
everybody it has to do with with Focus
this is so fascinating when you
understand it of course we know that you
need rest right of course we know that
you've got to put yourself to bed so
that your body can rest you need it but
do you know the real reason
why your brain needs you to sleep
I'm going to tell you
when you're asleep
half of your brain
can turn off
and go into an autopilot mode
and the other half of your brain
gets to go to work doing something
critically important for your success
while this part of the brain is on
autopilot and asleep
this part of the brain takes your
experience from today
and starts filing away
all of the things that happened to you
today all the memories all of the
lessons all of the skill building
absolutely everything that happened you
day gets filed away like books returning
to a library system
if you didn't sleep you wouldn't have
any memories
and so it's critically important
for your ability to focus
for your ability to build knowledge for
your ability to become stronger and more
resilient
for your ability to be productive for
you to sleep so that you can take
everything that happened today and while
you're busy sleeping you can store it
away as knowledge that you're building
on
you must visualize the steps that lead
you
to the thing that you want
not the end goal this is a major mistake
that people make they manifest
improperly because all they do is focus
on the end goal if you've ever made a
vision board think about what you put on
the vision board you put up just the
beach house or the million dollars in
the bank or you crossing the finish line
or you launching that business or you
having the body that you want or you
would drive in the Maserati whatever it
is the end goal is what you put up on a
vision board that is not what you're
going to do when you manifest if you
start focusing on crossing the finish
line of the marathon that is a one-way
ticket to being unmotivated and
completely discouraged in fact research
shows that if all you do is focus on the
thing that you want and you just focus
on that vision of you and your bikini
body or you with the love of your life
on your arms or you at the Oscars
winning that award or the Grammys
what happens is because you've only
focused on the end goal you start to
feel really unmotivated and discouraged
because you're nowhere near it that's
where manifesting comes in because we're
not going to focus on the end goal you
gotta pick something that you want in
order to get started but manifesting
isn't about the end it's about the
bridge
it's about going from where you are here
to where you want to go
imagine that there is a bridge
that connects where you are right here
with what you dream about doing
now that dream could be to be a Grammy
award-winning
singer-songwriter that dream might be to
have a family of your own that dream
might be to have a beach house or a ski
house or to take a trip to Fiji that
dream can be whatever the hell you want
it to be but when it comes to
manifesting once you've given yourself
permission to dream with the lid off and
really want what you want to feel the
pull of that thing now we gotta talk
about the path that connects where you
are with where you want to go and this
is all about visualizing the Little
Steps there's a lot of research that
proves why visualizing the steps is the
most important thing that you could do
there was a study done at UCLA for
example where they were researching
manifestation and the power of
visualization and they broke students
into two groups and they had group a
we're going to call these the vision
board group they had group a closed
their eyes visualize in their mind and
feel in their body
themselves taking the test and then
walking up to a board where the tests
scores were posted and finding their
name and seeing an A plus that's what
group a the vision board group we're
told to do to visualize themselves
achieving what they wanted
Group B
we're going to call these the hard
workers these students were coached in
this research project to close their
eyes and to visualize going back to
their dorm room sitting down at the desk
and studying and staying up late and
putting in the work studying and
preparing for the tests
and let me ask you a question
which group do you think did better on
the actual test
was it group a the vision board group
who were taught to visualize and picture
themselves walking up to a board and
seeing the a plus
or was it Group B
the hard work group the group that was
taught to close their eyes and visualize
and seeing themselves doing the work to
study for the test
well if you answered group a you're
wrong
if you answered Group B you got the
correct answer the reason why Group B
the students who visualize studying for
the test got better test scores is
because when you visualize yourself
doing the work visualizing it leads you
to doing the work and it's only through
actions that you will get the result
that you want preparing your mind and
visualizing yourself doing it lowers
your resistance and leads to you taking
the action that's why manifesting works
you know the same is true in sports
there's all kinds of research in sports
psychology in fact our Olympic athletes
for the U.S Olympic team they hire
Sports psychologists to train our top
Olympic athletes particularly after
they've been injured in visualizing
themselves competing when you coach an
athlete to mentally rehearse every
single detail about going through the
competition you are training the mind
body and spirit to show up and dominate
this is is particularly true for
athletes after they've been injured and
they're stepping back into competition
if you've been injured in competition
you're naturally going to feel anxious
you're naturally going to be nervous
your brain and nervous system circuitry
is now programmed with the intensity
from that injury the memory from the
injury so of course it's natural to
bring that in to your pre-competition
feelings about it right so manifestation
properly remember what it is manifesting
is preparing your mind body and spirit
to do the work it's aligning your mind
body and spirit with what you want it
removes the obstacles that would
normally stop you which then prepares
and motivates you to take the actions to
succeed so in the case of athletes who
visualize themselves and see themselves
doing all the steps over and over
they're removing the nerves they're
removing all the programming related to
the injury they are prepared their mind
body and spirit to go in and freaking
Dominate and so are you tell me is there
some project
or some area of your life
or
a business or a goal or some change that
you want to make
that you feel like you think about all
the time but you just can't seem to push
through
all of that thinking or push through the
the the fatigue or the overwhelm or how
do I get started right
you can't seem to just push through is
there some area of your life where you
feel that way
if so I want you to write it in the
comments okay I see I want to work with
animals I see somebody going oh my gosh
I keep thinking about doing a tick tock
account oh I want to get control of my
addiction oh I want to launch your
business oh I really want to get a
degree but I feel like it's too late
um and you may be telling yourself uh
that uh things just feel like it's too
late now like I I got a divorce and now
it feels like my life is frozen I see
some of you saying I feel like ever
since I got the divorce or the pandemic
hit or I lost the job or I took the
wrong job or I moved to the wrong place
or I realized that I wanted to start
this thing and I started it but now it's
stalled out and I'm embarrassed to keep
starting I want to finish my PhD I want
to be persistent with the gym I want to
get back to creating art I see all the
stuff that you all are writing down it's
beautiful I see so many of you saying
that you have a little side hustle and
you know that you want to turn your
attention towards it but you just can't
seem
to literally push through whatever it is
the fear the overwhelm the business of
your life to laser focus
on what really matters to you
and I think that's why it's so painful
because you're not going to stop really
wanting and longing for those things
that you keep thinking about everybody
they're going to linger for the rest of
your life
you're gonna have to at some point make
a decision
that it is important enough to you
to make changes so that the thing that
you want to see happen or the life that
you don't want to miss out on
or the degree that you always
longed to get
or the way that you want to feel in your
body or the energy for me a big theme uh
recently has been about loneliness I am
so lonely in my personal life because of
the pandemic because our kids had
launched because we're moving to Vermont
because I'm always working like I can
see very clearly
that I have tried to solve loneliness in
my personal life by working all the time
and that's not the right solution for
loneliness and so I even see all this
and so
I'm glad that you can see an area of
your life where you feel this friction
and tension because you know that you
want to focus more time and energy there
but there's so much resistance and
there's so much friction and there's so
much else going on that it is robbing
you of the ability
to push forward toward the life that you
really want to be living
and look it's not going to happen
overnight but so let me tell you let me
tell you
this sentence this truth about life that
I truly love that that always kicks me
in the rear end honestly and here it is
no one is coming
that's it no one's coming
no one is going to come into your life
and do the work for you no one is going
to come into your life and uh just
remove your problems no one is going to
come into your life and make your dreams
come true
when it comes to the changes that you
want to make when it comes to the things
that you long for in your heart when it
comes to the music that you want to put
out into the world or the tick tock
account that you want to create or the
degree that you want to get or the life
you want to build after divorce or after
your partner dies or after you know you
change jobs or after the kids launch
when it comes to those things that you
deeply long for deserve and desire no
one's coming
you are not too late
if you're breathing you're watching this
video you have plenty of time
to create a life that makes you happy to
create a life that is full of meaning
for you whatever that means you have
plenty of time to take control to heal
it is so important for you to hear that
that you have plenty of time
but no one's coming
at some point you have to make a
decision and you'll often hear me say
you're one decision away
from a different life a better life
but you have to make the decision no
one's coming to make the decision for
you you have to decide
that you are done feeling beaten up
you're done
feeling lost you're done feeling stuck
you're done feeling isolated that all
that crap that you've been enduring
you're freaking done
you have to decide that I find that even
when change is exciting
it's still scary
even when you know that this big move
that you want to make this big goal that
you want to achieve is something that
you're meant to do
even though you know it it feels
overwhelming
we found an incredible apartment in
Boston and
um are negotiating right now a place and
I had nightmares last night about this
apartment nightmares why well because
anything new any change that you want to
make is going to require you to
literally
end things in your old life you see I
think that so many of us we are really
there are two lives that we have there's
the life that you're currently living
and then there's the one
that you're going to live next hello
whoever's flying that jet I'm going to
say that again we all have two lives
the life you're currently living
and the life
you're going to launch next
and when you're in the middle of
thinking about changes and making big
changes in your life I feel like it's
almost like you're walking across a
suspension bridge as you're building it
and so I have become so indecisive about
everything like I noticed last night I
was trying to reach out to somebody that
was recommended to me as a potential uh
person to hire as an executive producer
for this big podcast for launching this
fall in Boston
and I couldn't even get myself focused
to write the email
now the reason why is because when
you're on edge when you're overwhelmed
when you feel stressed or scared about
something your nervous system kicks into
a state of alert and that impacts your
brain's ability to focus so what do you
need when you feel that way I'll tell
you what you need you need to hit the
freaking reset button you need to get
your mindset back in check you gotta
focus on the simple things that you can
do every day to make yourself feel
steady and secure and clear even as
everything is changing around you if you
expect to achieve your goals if you
expect to
reach your potential if you expect to
have your dreams come true what I'm
about to explain to you is Mission
critical you must become a master at
visualization
now
for those of you
that are like what the heck is she
talking about I did not sign up for some
sort of meditation woo-woo spiritual
thing here
don't worry this is Mel Robbins there's
always science and research involved in
everything that I talk about
so visualization is a extraordinarily
powerful skill
and you may have heard of the law of
attraction
you may have heard of the word
visualization you may have heard of the
word manifesting
I call it
um
seeing signs
so I'm a master at seeing positive signs
I am a master of creating coincidences I
have the world's most incredible luck
you want to know why because I
understand the science and the skill of
visualization
I know that your brain it is a gigantic
detective machine your brain is a filter
your brain is constantly looking for
evidence and that's good news it's good
news when you know how to use it to your
advantage let me explain
so your brain has a system in it here's
the technical term it's called the
reticular activating system
it is a network of neurons all up in
here and what is the job of the
reticular activating system it is a
filter system
it's basically a system that allows
certain information in your brain and it
blocks out other information
and guess who programmed that filter you
did and so did the people from your past
and so if you constantly feel like
you're unlovable guess what your
reticular activating system is going
through the day and it is going to point
out every single piece of evidence that
confirms that negative belief that you
have if you think that people don't like
you at work the reticular activating
system the filter it is literally going
to be looking for evidence to confirm
that belief all day long this is one of
the reasons why we have such a problem
with politics in this country this is
why there's something called a
confirmation bias confirmation bias
means your mind loves to read things
that you agree with because reading
things that you agree with confirms your
filter why do we have a particular
activating system there's a really
important reason why you have this the
reason why is if your brain let in
everything
have you ever looked
at a Facebook page
have you noticed how many words are on a
standard Facebook page and the ad over
here and the ad over here and the ad
over here and the ad in the zoo seed
right here and the stuff up here and all
this over here
if your brain took in everything at
equal value your head would literally
explode off your shoulders your brain
would melt down and so the reticular
activating system
protects your brain by filtering
information and only letting in stuff
that it agrees with
so
that's the scientific reason and mandate
for why you got to get busy
reprogramming that thing because if you
live like I have lived for a very long
time one of the beliefs that I had we're
going to be talking about this a lot
this month one of the beliefs that I had
for a very long time is that I was a bad
person
that I was not lovable that
um I did not deserve to be a good person
that people didn't think I was a good
person and consequently that led me to
do a lot of hurtful things to myself it
led me to do a lot of hurtful things to
uh people that I cared about and it it
really damaged Decades of my life and I
believed it I believed it and it drove
my actions and I saw evidence everywhere
if you're going to do a mindset reset
you've got to change what you believe
about yourself and so for those of you
that had a very negative uh assessment
of 2018 and you're feeling down about
your goals already as you look at 2019
you have a very negative belief system
about yourself and that's going to stop
right now number one the secret to an
optimistic mindset you got to be
maniacal about your intake
negativity in here means negativity in
your body gets stored here and
negativity comes out here
it becomes this Loop of negativity and
so in order to build a positive mindset
I want you to be maniacal about positive
input that means really watch your news
intake do not be watching it every day
get the facts
get what you need to know from a trusted
measured
calm factual source and then turn that
[ __ ] off okay that's number one number
two edit your social media
anything on your social media feeds
should be helping you be more resilient
more optimistic
more
um positive
anything
that you're following that triggers you
that is negative that rubs you the wrong
way you know one of the things that I've
noticed
I have some favorite celebrities that I
have um followed for a while because I
think they're funny or I love
um
just kind of their sense of humor but
there are so many people that I have
muted right now because I think that
what they're doing online is so freaking
out of whack seeing people give us
advice about quarantining from the back
of their Estates and mansions telling us
to donate when they're not saying
they're donating seeing this kind of
tone deaf uh celebrity thing going on
I'm normally not a negative person about
that but I have muted muted muted so
many accounts because it's not doing
anything for me and you got to be
selfish right now you have got to edit
your social media feeds so that your
social media feeds are helping you build
an optimistic and positive mindset and
so every day the second I see someone at
mute mute mute mute unfollow unfollow
unfollow because negativity in means
negativity gets stored here means
negativity goes out there from you you
want to put positivity optimism tools
strategies things that keep you laughing
keep things that keep you giving you
things that you can use right now the
second you start getting overloaded with
Corona stuff mute that stuff edit edit
edit your social media based on what you
need that's number one maniacal about
your intake you want to focus on what's
in your control okay
that's what you want to do if you're
going through a divorce you're waiting
for lawyers and this process of
anticipation this process of having to
be patient the first thing that you need
to do is ask yourself and this is by the
way stuff that I talk about in the high
five habit book this is about how to
cultivate a high five attitude when
things are out of your control how to
cultivate a high five attitude when you
are waiting and are feeling this
anticipation how to cultivate a high
five attitude when you might be
disappointed I mean you're not going to
have everything be a win in life and so
rule number one
you want to put a hundred and fifty
percent
effort in on something that you care
about okay so if you are sitting here
and you're waiting to hear back on
something or you're waiting to do
something you want to ask yourself if I
put a hundred and fifty percent in one
of the reasons why I just fired off
literally a three-page detailed email to
this landlord basically saying these
girls need a win they all have uh jobs
after working uh internships uh their
senior year they are respectful they're
not looking at your house like a frat
house like so many other people will
they need individual rooms in case they
have to work remote like I went boom
boom boom boom boom they're looking for
a home why did I do that because I think
it's really important when you are
trying to uh make something happen in
your life
really important when you're going for
something that you can personally say to
yourself I have done a hundred and fifty
percent I have gone all in okay and so I
feel like yeah we went all in we got our
application in we got the check
submitted we got the uh Love Letter
submitted and now what I do when I'm
waiting
is I literally say I've put in a hundred
and fifty percent I can give myself that
high five I can look the woman in the
mirror and I can say I know I did
everything that I could what will eat
you alive everybody
is if you're waiting and you know that
you didn't put 150 percent in
it will eat you alive to be
waiting to hear back on a job or on
um you know some test results or on an
application to a program or a school and
to know that you didn't put in a hundred
and fifty percent that's what's going to
cause the disappointment letting go is
really really hard
you are going to start a new chapter in
your life when you're going to try to
launch yourself forward it requires you
to let go and the reason why letting go
of
whatever it may be a relationship a
friendship a job my case the place that
you lived for the 24 years the reason
why letting go is so hard is because we
tend to grip very tightly to things that
are familiar
and when you grip really tightly to the
things that you know
it's going to be really hard in fact
it's going to be impossible to launch
yourself forward
and we grip really tightly to the things
that we know
[Music]
um because it feels safe
and the truth is change is really really
really hard because you're holding on to
things that are no longer meant for you
if this is speaking to you I want you to
write into the comments right now what
are you holding on to
whether it's out of fear or self-doubt
or overwhelm you're just gripping so
tightly
what are you holding on to that you know
is no longer meant for you I guarantee
you you're probably going to write a
friendship a job a relationship
uh maybe it's a way of eating or
treating your body
maybe it's a way of thinking that you're
holding on to maybe you're just gripping
tightly to staying stressed and tense
and in a state of fear
you can hold on to a way of thinking and
that can keep you stuck for decades
I wanted to bring this up because I have
been thinking a lot about this idea of
gripping and holding on
and I think if you if you've followed me
for a while
probably heard me say that you are one
decision away
from a different life
better life a life that is full of more
joy
full of Happiness full of you feeling
connected and alive and just engaged in
your life again just one decision away
and the first decision
that will change everything is to let go
to stop gripping and to find the
confidence and the courage and the
clarity to let go of what's no longer
serving you
and to turn yourself toward what you
truly want in your life if you know the
moment that you started to think wow I
got to change myself to fit in I can't
be gay I can't have kinky hair I don't
like the color of my skin because I feel
like there's something wrong with me
Society gave you that message your
parents did
maybe a bully said something to you I
see somebody writing the way that I walk
I see somebody talking about the texture
of their hair I see somebody saying I
always felt like there was something
wrong with me well let me tell you
something everybody I never fit in with
any particular groups of friends let me
tell you something every one of you is
now going I remember that feeling
because I was the only immigrant in my
class I was the only Muslim in my class
I didn't look like the other people I
didn't feel like the other people my
father was so critical right right
when you start to get this message from
society or other people or just this
perception that you have that
something's wrong with you this is where
your obsession with changing yourself to
fit in begins this is where your
obsession with people pleasing this is
where this sense that you don't belong
anywhere that you go began and it can
become a habit and so we're going to
unpack this because what I want you to
understand is that you literally
you literally came into this world
perfect whole and complete
you are wired to love yourself you're
wired for love that's why you miss it
you're wired for self-acceptance and the
world taught you
that there's something about you that
needs to be changed in order to be liked
or loved and it's simply not true
when you can come back home to yourself
and you can accept and love yourself
first exactly where you are exactly
where you're not
then you'll know the secret to going out
in the world and not feeling like you
never really belong anywhere or you
constantly need to tweak yourself or how
you show up in order to be accepted by
people when you accept yourself as you
are when you love yourself as you are
other people liking or loving you is
just a bonus but it doesn't change how
you feel about yourself and one of the
things that will help you to do the work
to create the things that you want in
your life
is it will help you if you train your
mind
to start spotting evidence as you're
doing the work as you're going through
your day it will help you if you train
your mind to start scanning the world
and spotting evidence that yes indeed
the world is sending you positive
signals that things are going to work
out now why is it important to train
your mind to help you get what you want
well the reason why is because if you
get into a negative mindset if you start
thinking
this business is never going to work why
even bother I'm never going to meet
anybody it's nothing but losers out
there look at all these idiots on hinge
why the hell should I keep doing this if
you allow your mind to start to rest in
a pessimistic negative protective scared
and doubtful stance your mind will
continue to show you reasons why there's
nobody on hinged worth talking to your
mind will continue to show you all the
reasons why you will never make it in
business your mind will continue to show
you all the reasons why you're never
going to lose that weight and be able to
tuck in your shirt as my friend Corinne
Crabtree always talks about that
transformational moment and when your
mind goes negative your mind starts to
scan the world and will show you more
reasons to stop and the power of
training your mind to spot positive
signs is very simple the power is that
your mind will start to show you reasons
to keep going your mind will help you
take the step your mind will encourage
you to feel optimistic to feel empowered
just like you woke up today on a Tuesday
and it was February 22nd 2022 and those
numbers are lining up and that makes you
in your heart and soul go whoa something
cool could happen today like that [ __ ]
only happens like once in my lifetime
those numbers are going to line up like
that today is a really cool date let's
go do something with this you could
create that kind of attitude every
single freaking day of your life you
could if you train your mind and if you
start taking action and training your
mind is the key piece that we're going
to talk about
so for those of you that have read the
high five habit one of the things that I
talk about a lot is every single day
find a naturally occurring heart-shaped
object in the world it could be a stone
it could be a leaf it could be a cloud
it could be a shape in your coffee hey
Chris if we've got anything around here
that looks like a heart hand it to me
and the reason why I love telling you to
start playing a game with yourself well
you start your day going mind brain show
me some heart oh what is this come here
dog treat oh my God it's a dog treat
look at this guys
what shape is that
that right there is a harp
there we go check that out
if you say brain mind show me a heart
today guess what's gonna happen that
damn dog biscuit it's gonna show it's
gonna you're gonna be like there's a
heart you're gonna look out at the sky
and you're gonna see a heart shape oh
right there in the mountains there's a
heart shape in the mountains in southern
Vermont you're going to see it in the
clouds what you're doing when you tell
your mind what's important to you is
you're telling your mind and the filter
in your brain to change in real time and
allow into your consciousness
what's important to you and if you want
to see hearts by God those damn dog
treats are going to start looking like
hearts everybody that's how you train
your mind it's freaking incredible and
if you want to see evidence of this
follow me on social media if you follow
me Mel Robbins on social media you will
see every day I am reposting your
stories of finding heart shapes around
the world now why is this important well
it's important because it's a simple way
to prove to you that your mind changes
in real time that if you get serious
about becoming more positive and
optimistic and encouraging of yourself
if you get serious about saying this I
don't want to see all the reasons why
I'm unhappy I don't want to see
everybody else in the world that's
launched a business or that's lost
weight and is healthy or that has a
really good marriage or relationship and
I don't want to see that and and have my
mind process it as evidence that it's
never going to happen for me I want my
mind to reprogram itself and see other
people's businesses and see other people
getting healthy and see other people in
relationships and I want my mind to say
yeah if they can do it I can do it
that's evidence if that person can get
healthy so can I if that person can find
somebody on hinge so can I if that
person can reconcile with their child so
can I other people can become evidence
that you can have it too right now your
mind is so [ __ ] up from your past that
when you see what other people have and
you don't have it you can't actually
translate it through a negative mind and
and see that that's evidence that you're
going to win you see it like oh somebody
already stole what I wanted that sucks
and so what I want to start to open your
mind to is that you have the power to
train your mind
to filter the world differently just
like you woke up and you saw the date
today 2 22 22 and your brain saw that
was like whoa this is a once in a
lifetime day everybody
you are never going to have another day
that lines up like this ever
what are you going to do with this day
your mind already interpreted this as
wow
something cool could happen
and if you tell yourself something
amazing is going to happen today
something will because you're going to
be looking for it I swear to God
something will something will if you
want to see the good all around you you
got to tell your mind you want to see
the good and this just isn't a bunch of
horsesh everybody this isn't toxic
positivity there is a filter in your
brain called the reticular activating
system
the reticular activating system I call
it the RAS I like to think about it like
a giant hair net on your head and this
Ras sits over your brain I'm probably
getting this wrong I'm not a
neuroscientist I could give about
getting it right I just need you to know
the basics here so that you can apply it
to your life okay you don't need a PhD
to use the science that super smart
people have been working really hard on
in order to apply it to your life that's
what I'm here for in your life I'm here
to translate this stuff into simple
believable and actionable things that
you can do to take all this super cool
stuff that people are researching and
apply it to your normal person's
everyday life to help you change from
the inside out and one of the coolest
things that you have at your disposal is
you have a whole system in your body
that you can train and change and one of
those things that you can train and
change that is impacted by that real
that word you're hearing a lot of
neuroplasticity that just means that
things are able to twist and bend and
change and you're able to learn new
things for as long as you're alive as
long as you're breathing everybody you
got a chance to change the way that you
think as long as you are breathing you
got a chance to change from the inside
out how you experience your life as long
as you are still here watching me people
you got a chance to create a new
experience in your life and one of the
things that helps a lot is understanding
that right now all of the Bulls from
your past has jammed the filter in your
mind body and spirit the reticular
activating system and it is clouding
your ability to look at the world around
you and see hearts remember this dog
treat hearts look at that there's a
heart right there
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to see my
recent interview with Mel Robbins one on
one check the video right there next to
me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there I hope
your business goes bankrupt Evan Evan
you're a terrible person I spent the
first 40 some years of my life trying to
be somebody else I'll give you guys a
secret way